so the women in that household starting
with Kris Jenner at the top top of the
food chain they're they're doing just
fine I think Kylie's the youngest
billionaire ever
uh Kim's a billionaire Chloe's got money
uh Kendall's doing her thing she's
literally the top top model in the world
top most highest paid model in the world
but they all got money the women are
doing just fine in that in that family
but what happens to the men number one
you're the father you represent OJ and
then you die
okay straight up die Robert Kardashian
dead now Robert Jr Robert Kardashian is
a recluse hasn't been seen in years I
think he's on the verge of 300 something
pounds he knocked up Blac Chyna horrible
decision he knocked up the epitome of a
304 and he hasn't been seen in years
then you got Lamar Odom All-Star stud
NBA championship marries Chloe next
thing you know rehab almost dies
overdose get it together holy you got
Scott Disick in and out of rehab that
was my homie at one point but holy sh
did they ruin that guy's life